[Musique]
on suit bien sûr de près et on entend
encore d'ailleurs le son est-ce qu'il va
se passer au cours des prochaines heures
avec ces inondations Christiane Jacques
bonsoir bonsoir Journée Internationale
des Travailleurs 1er mai en 2023 ça
signifie quoi encore ça Jacques mais
c'est la fête des travailleurs des
travailleurs mais c'est plus que ça
c'est une façon de se rappeler que il y
a des gens avant nous qui se sont battus
qui ont mené des luttes sociales des
luttes ouvrières ça commence aux
Etats-Unis dans les abattoirs de la
région de Chicago à l'époque avec même
des affrontements violents des
pendaisons de leaders syndicaux c'est de
là que ça vient le premier mai des
luttes pour la réduction de la semaine
de travail et à chaque année depuis que
moi je suis les activités syndicales le
mouvement syndical il y a manifestation
il y a une grande marche pour se
rappeler effectivement qu'il y a eu des
travailleurs dans l'amiante qui ont eu
des travailleurs dans le coton dans le
textile qui se sont battus pour
améliorer les conditions de travail les
conditions salariale améliorer les
conditions de santé sécurité donc c'est
la fête des travailleurs mais c'est
aussi une façon de se rappeler en France
c'est un jour férié j'aurais aimé ça que
le ministre annonce ce matin que non il
le pas annoncé on a la fête du travail
la fête du travail quand même c'est le
modèle américain est-ce que est-ce que
Christiane nous travailleur sont les
mieux traités du monde ça c'est comme se
demander si nos joueurs de hockey sont
les meilleurs mais en réponse à votre
question j'ai regardé dans le fond trois
dimensions la vue de l'étranger le
Canada de Québec et puis quelques points
améliorés alors de l'étranger là c'est
sûr qu'on est la terre promise
énormément les 500 000
postes pour des immigrants vont être
comblés il y a beaucoup de gens qui
veulent venir au Canada les valeurs la
conciliation travail l'équité la
capacité en partant de rien d'avoir des
enfants qui vont se retrouver à
l'université puis être parmi les
meilleurs c'est pas possible
puis au Canada écoutez des études là
c'est un travailleur sur deux est heure
au Québec on aime du championnat on a 7
sur 10 de nos travailleurs qui sont
heureux mais le point clé là je parle
pas pour ma paroisse c'est que
l'engagement des femmes vous savez que
le Québec les femmes au Québec ont le
deuxième plus grand engagement mondial
après la Suède sur le marché du travail
ça doit faire qu'elles sont bien
traitées plus de 83%, donc on est une
nation ou je pense que les gens sont
heureux travaille bien il y a peut-être
des choses améliorées on le vu les
travailleurs temporaires les accidents
de travail mais sommes toutes je pense
qu'on est
d'accord
c'est que c'était le taux de
syndicalisation le plus élevé ah au
Québec est-ce que c'est ça le point clé
ça explique pas mal d'affaires on va
essayer les garderies non non pour les
femmes c'est les garderies
pour le système de garderie que l'on
connaisseurs
35 40% de travailleurs syndiqués au
Québec
au Canada le niveau de syndicalisation
citoyen les plus heureux dans le monde
mais en Ontario il est quand même assez
considérable en tant de principe à
l'Alliance de la fonction publique qui
s'organise le gouvernement sans aucun
doute écouter les syndicats voulaient
4,5 % pour 3 ans et puis on se retrouve
avec une entente à 12,6 pour 4 ans ça
c'est prêt juste un petit peu plus que
3% par an pour 4 ans
Orient coup mais je pense qu'un coup qui
est beaucoup moins de que ce que les
syndicats souhaitaient puis surtout le
le les travailleurs le droit de
l'employeur décider où le travailleur va
travailler maintenu même s'il
travailleur aura une meilleure
relocation
télétravail n'est pas enchassé dans la
convention collective on nous dit que ça
va être au cas par cas faut faire
attention faut faire attention moi
d'abord
gagnant-gagnant d'abord le gouvernement
a pas légiférer Christiane croyait qu'il
y avait une loi spéciale
moi je crois ah mais moi je croyais que
parle la voix du dialogue et puis de la
négociation que c'était possible de
s'entendre surtout que les deux parties
étaient pas si éloignés donc moi ce que
je comprends du côté syndical c'est
qu'on est satisfait de l'entendre
négocié c'est quand même du 3 %
d'augmentation par année et sur le
télétravail il faut être extrêmement
prudent parce qu'une lettre d'entente
c'est un excès une convention collective
alors oui c'est vrai c'est pas un
article de la convention mais c'est une
lettre qui est indexée donc c'est
négocié c'est discuter c'est différent
d'une politique qui est générale c'est
applicable par des départements par
métier ou par ministère et vous pouvez
même déposer un grillage sur une lettre
d'entente donc j'entendais aujourd'hui
ben des gens dire c'est pas dans
convention collective il faut la
convention une instance c'est un excès
de convention collective parfait salaire
minimum Jacques qui monte d'un dollar à
15 et 25 on atteint 15 dollars qui
étaient revendiqué pendant des années
aujourd'hui on revendique que du côté
syndical notamment les 18 de là c'est un
grand pas quand même pour le Québec
d'être à 15 et 25 d'augmenter d'un
dollars
on avait fait une entrevue l'ancien
président de la FTQ Daniel Boyer pour
disait ça prend le 15 dollars mais il y
a 4 ans oui et là déjà le ministre
disait non non on va l'atteindre dans
deux trois quatre ans écoutez moi je
trouve que c'est insuffisant d'ailleurs
j'entendais le ministre tantôt ne pas
répondre à votre question sur le fait
que il y a de moins en moins de monde au
salaire minimum ça veut dire que donc
qui est passé élevé la réponse est oui
il est pas assez élevé et d'ailleurs les
travailleurs de façon
dans le contexte de la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre en profite et s'assure des
augmentations de salaire mais 15 dollars
ce n'est pas suffisant même à 18 c'est
difficile de vivre au-dessus de seuil de
pauvreté Christiane je pense qu'on se
rapproche l'Ontario ça c'est important
on avait déjà parlé il y a 10 ans le
l'Ontario avancé parce que l'Ontario
augmente le 1er octobre 16 et quelque
chose il y avait juste 15 sous qui
séparait le Québec de l'Ontario qui
était en avant et puis maintenant c'est
plus d'un dollar 30 en
qui est raisonnable il y a l'éducation
la capacité de vivant française mais je
pense qu'on doit être parmi les
meilleurs on a des plus grosses
économies au pays et c'était dû en même
temps ça peut pas 18 dollars de l'heure
il y a quand même des commerces de
détails qui ont à s'ajuster mais il y en
a beaucoup qui sont déjà ajustés puis
c'est pour ça que moi ils travaillent ça
leur minimum
la manifestation est toujours très forte
en France pour le premier mai cette
année ça a tourné à la violence voici
quelques images
[Applaudissements]
alors le gouvernement Macron bien sûr il
y a la réforme de des retraites en ce
moment passé de 62 à 64 ans notamment
l'âge de la retraite c'est très tendu
Christiane présentement en France est-ce
que le gouvernement a raison malgré ces
manifestations parce que c'est aussi ça
la colère de persister dans sa réforme
écoutez dans tous les pays il faut qu'il
y a un équilibre entre les gens qui
paient puis les gens qui reçoivent des
prestations de retraite et puis vous
savez que même le seuil qu'on a ici de
65 ans ça date de 1916 en Allemagne les
Allemands avaient décrété que 65 ans
c'est une bonne âge après le président
Roosevelt comme le 135 a dit mais on va
établir 65 ans parce que ça oui ça va
s'équilibrer en s'occuper puis ceux qui
reçoivent sauf que dans l'état l'âge
moyen de l'espérance de vie était même
pas de 65 ans pour les hommes peut-être
chez les femmes donc on a besoin
maintenant une espérance de vie qui est
au-delà de 80 ans d'avoir des
ajustements donc il a raison de
persister
le régime de retraite publique par
répartition en France il est
excédentaire en 2021 en 2022 donc vous
allez avoir autant d'avis que
d'actuaires en Europe sur va-t-il bien
ou pas bien mais au-delà au-delà est-ce
que le régime va bien s'il y a autant de
monde dans les rues puis là je voyais
des manifestations où ça casse mais ça
c'est pas les 800000 personnes qui se
sont battues avec la police ça c'est les
casseurs mais vous savez pourquoi il y a
autant de gens dans la rue parce que ça
pénalise les bosses salariés c'est à
dire que les bosses salariés commencent
à travailler jeunes et tôt et c'est eux
qui vont travailler plus longtemps parce
que un professionnel qui sort de
l'université à 30 ans donc c'est pour ça
que la population en France est
mobilisée et compte les positions parce
que il devrait reculer moi je pense
qu'il ne reculera pas mais il devrait
reculer parce qu'il est pas légitimé du
tout du tout c'est pas le dialogue
social j'en ai parlé tantôt dans
l'entente avec Ottawa s'il y a des
problèmes au régime de retraite patron
syndicat s’assoit trouve des solutions
en général on en trouve on avait
beaucoup de sujets ce soir faut
s'arrêter ici on reprendra la discussion
sur les réformes de retraite c'est
intéressant Christian et Jacques merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]